hillary duff has welcomed a new bundle
of joy
so it's been very hard to even contain
my excitement the actress gave birth to
her third child
making her and husband matthew koma a
family of five
they both share two-year-old daughter
banks while hillary also shares her
eight-year-old son luca
with ex-husband mike comrie i just keep
keep juggling it you know
hillary shared her pregnancy news back
in october via instagram
showing off a boomerang of her growing
baby bump with the caption
we are growing mostly me oh my god
hillary and matthew got married in
december 2019
and just last month matthew posted a
heartfelt message for their one year
anniversary
writing quote how you're able to be the
mom individual
wife spirit and tie-dye influencer you
are
while making it look so easy is
mind-boggling
and i don't know what i did right to
deserve being on the receiving end of it
it's pretty insane when e.t caught up
with hillary in 2018
she opened up about balancing her family
it's like school pick up and then he
usually has an after school activity and
i'm like nursing the baby
after school activity and then we're
like running home and it's like
homework and dinner and bath time and
trying to be fun
and you know continue like our whole
regimen and you
i just have a baby on my boob the whole
entire time so it's pretty insane
and um and amazing at the same time you
just do it you know you just figure out
a way to do it